50 of the population hates you because
of your ideology
you had to be a little bit crazy to be
an entrepreneur so if you had to bet on
who you think is going to win the
election
who would you put money on
today's episode of model masters is
brought to you by tubebuddy
tubebuddy is your best friend on your
road to youtube success
i use it every day on my channel to get
more views and subscribers
automate the boring tasks and split test
my thumbnails and titles
i've done over 3 800 split tests which
have led to results like taking this 5
year old video
that was getting 250 views a day and
just by changing the thumbnail
it blew up to 15 000 views per day
you can get started on tubebuddy for
free at tubebuddy.com
believe nation welcome to the kevin and
evan show where i sit down
with kevin o'leary and we take your
questions
people are tough and mean in business
how do you manage not getting taken
advantage of
why don't you answer that one first i
think you're going to get taken
advantage of like i think at some point
part of the process of being an
entrepreneur is you will get taken
advantage of i think that is part of
business and you take your lumps and you
learn along the way
uh i think though every single time
that that happens you just take the
lesson and you say hey
i maybe had an instinct i maybe found
something seemed a little bit off with
that person i'm gonna learn i'm gonna
get better
next time but i don't think that you
only have to be
tough no you don't have to be tough but
i think it's healthy to be a skeptic
i really do i think being a skeptic
makes you
test your own assumptions and those of
others around you and always ask
yourself is this person telling me the
truth and can i validate it
is there any way i can know with
certainty that this is correct
and if you remain a skeptic until you
prove it out and the other thing
you know evan i look at is what's the
reputation of somebody i mean
you over time you build your own brand
if you're an entrepreneur
you start to realize that you work in a
world of many other people interacting
with you and they make assumptions about
you and they learn more and more over
time about who you are
you can't shortcut a reputation you have
to build it
and it takes a long time to build it up
and it's very easy to destroy and the
way you destroy it is you start lying to
people
i'll just trust people by default maybe
that's maybe that's not great
you must get screwed over a lot then i
don't though i mean
i don't know i i don't get screwed over
a ton
uh maybe i haven't built up a big enough
you know brand or recognition where
people are
um you know stopping me every day on the
street but if if i'm hiring somebody on
my team
i'll just trust them by default and they
have to show me obviously there's
there's instincts like do i like this
person or not but
once they passed that you know evan
thinks you're a good person test then i
just i just trust people by default and
it it really
i don't know it hasn't really come back
to really screw over my business
i've learned a different tact what i do
is i try and bring someone into a
company or in my own group
for six months on a trial basis to see
if they interact with the team and tell
them honestly and transparently look
we don't know if it's going to work why
don't you come in as an intern why don't
you check it out
how do you see how you feel and then if
we really gel
you stay on there's nothing worse than
bringing you know a cancer
into your body that's the way i look at
it and you want somebody that's on board
and can work with everybody else
and i like to hire very slowly and fire
very quickly and i tell that to all my
ceos
and i think people gravitate of they
might be too nice
and then one bad thing happens so then
they go and they say well now i'm gonna
be
extra tough yeah and and then you build
a different kind of culture but that's
not actually who you are and then you
try to
you know it's just finding that flow for
who you are in the kind of business you
want to build
but you want to be with people that want
to be with you and
everybody shares a common vision and i
think that's the new
entrepreneur 2.0 is making sure that
hey you have a social mission that you
care and you're all in sync with and b
or have a profit motivation because
that's how you keep the business intact
and if anybody's not on board with your
vision your direction
they shouldn't be there and they don't
they don't want to be there long term
so i i look at it and say are we all
singing from the same song sheet
let's test that every few months let's
sit around and ask each other is
everybody happy who's unhappy
and just bring it out i think that's
listen it sounds kumbaya but it works
so we've got 30 people on our team and i
think i'm toughest on the people who are
actually closest to me because really
because they appreciate
because i know what they could be and
they need to push to get there yeah
right like the people who you're
mentoring to carry along
the mission the vision and have
leadership roles in your company
to actually be a good mentor you have to
be hard and push them and show them what
they could become because they might
have a limited view of what
their potential is but somebody who's
entry level who messes up
i don't just have empathy i agree with
you but you know after
for me it's 36 months when you have been
with an organization for three years you
are ingrained in its dna
and you are expected to deliver you know
on your goals
and be part of the team and work towards
the common good
and all of that but you're in there it's
no longer you're an intern you're part
of the body and
and i remind people that all the time
it's this is not the beginning anymore
we're in the middle of the journey here
and so you have to perform and if you
all of a sudden can't do that
that's tough because look you can't keep
everybody
people screw up and it's one of the
hardest things to do as an entrepreneur
is to realize i have to take this person
out of the game you've got to be fair to
them but
you can't let one person taint the
mission of the business
and that's the hardest thing of being
the boss
how do you turn your hobby into a
business without growing bored or losing
their passion
i have a definition of what is a hobby
and what is a business
by saying if you can't make money within
36 months which is three years which is
a big number for me in business
it's just a hobby and it's not a
business if you're still losing money
after three years
you should treat it for what it is you
know a use of your time that is not
productive but you enjoy it for other
reasons
if you can't make it profitable after
all that time it is just a hobby and if
you're using all your time to spend on
it
then you're not an entrepreneur you're
not creating something where you can
create
jobs and provide services to people
you're just wasting your time and
wasting your money
take it behind the barn and shoot it
that's my definition
so i like to say i'm pretty aligned i
like to say that if you've got
something that you love doing but
doesn't bring value to the market then
it's just a hobby
and and it's great could be fulfilling
but it's not a business but if you're
just chasing opportunity
and you don't love it you're also going
to lose because you're going up against
people who love that thing
it's a big reason why i think a lot of
entrepreneurs fail is there they're
going to start a youtube channel they're
going to start a podcast they're going
to start a
whatever business but they never
actually liked it they just think it's
the hot opportunity for
the year well that is interesting and
then they fail
i think a lot of people fail because
they're not the right person the
opportunity is fantastic
but they never actually love the thing
or if you look at the entrepreneurs who
win they have a deep love for the actual
work that they're doing and so it's that
combination right
if it's just an opportunity you don't
love it you're not going to win and if
it's just something you love and there's
no
demand for it then then you've got a
hobby and it's in that marriage of what
do you love doing that can also be a
value to
other people that will pay you for you
know that's a really
good observation because you're always
competing
with somebody somewhere and these days
it's global and you've got to make the
assumption that the person you're
competing with
really loves what they do and they're
willing to work 25 hours a day and if
you're not if you're not
totally in love with it you're screwed
so i would argue an entrepreneur don't
start something that you don't have a
lot of passion for
because you're going to fail because
you're going to be competing with people
who do have that passion who
are motivated and i see that happen all
the time they just get
bored and you know maybe i've invested
in them and i can see that they're just
burned out
and if that happens you know quite often
i would say probably about 30 percent of
the time after a while they realize boy
this is hard work
yeah it is hard work running a business
is really hard work
but it's an added bonus if you can get
up in the morning and say i can't wait
to go fight the fight
because you know with certainty your
competitors doing that so that is a
theme that we can both agree on you
better love it baby
and you mentioned burnout in there uh
this it's a topic
now for a lot of youtubers feeling burnt
out from creating content
and and i think that's just a lot of
entrepreneurs face burnout
but if you love what you do i think it's
so much easier i mean i've done i've
been on youtube for
11 years we've done 6 000 public videos
11 000 or so
you know total videos and i still wake
up every day and we're
doing it and that's amazing i mean you
know you think about it you've turned
yourself into a broadcast entity that's
really what it is
and content is king and you have to keep
it fresh and interesting and different
all the time i get that
but i have to admit i'm a new newbie to
youtube but it's a very powerful vehicle
that's what i've learned
and it draws a new demographic i mean i
play on all the
on all of the social media platforms i
have millions of followers
but one thing i think you and i can
agree on it is a different
channel in terms of what it provides and
the demographic it achieves
and reaches and i get it i totally get
it now i kind of ignored it for a few
years but now i can't
so it's become a real element to my
weekly routine
i try and grab from experiences that i'm
having during the week and put it onto
my youtube channel and i'm brutally
honest about it
and sometimes i you know i stir the pot
and it
happens what can you do
you know that already i love it what
things should one learn by reading about
our first-hand experience before
becoming an entrepreneur
i mean i think the question is how do
you prepare yourself to be an
entrepreneur
i think surrounding yourself with
entrepreneurs is the easiest way
i think there's there's some you can
learn i think watching
watching youtube videos being around
shark tank
reading books like this like i think
that starts to give you the framework
but i think
the more you're actually around
entrepreneurs if that's what your goal
is to be an entrepreneur
be around the people who are doing the
thing that you want to do you know i
went to
university of toronto here and did four
years undergrad
bachelor commerce finance i didn't know
that i wanted to be an entrepreneur at
the time
so i'm still grateful that i went but i
took a
fourth year entrepreneurship course and
the professor teaching it
barely had a side business on his own
it's like well
who are you learning from right so if
you if you want to be a lawyer or a
doctor or
you know get those degrees then yeah you
need to be going to college and learn
because that degree matters but i don't
think you can learn it from a textbook
or learn it from a class i think the
best thing to do is to be around
people who are doing it if you have
entrepreneurs in your family or there's
a you know friend of yours hang out even
hang out their shop just to see how
they're doing it
and if you don't have that then
aspirational mentors is what i would
call
watching youtube videos or reading books
written
ideally by the person not just about
them but
by the person sharing their lessons to
to have it be part of your ecosystem
i've come to a new place in my
understanding what works and doesn't i
also went through the educational
process i did an mba and people ask me
does that have anything to do with
success or failure and i say no it
doesn't
i don't remember a single thing i
learned there for the two years
except the people i met that that now
are out there in the world
as bankers and lawyers and whatever else
they are and i use them as my bit
database of
contacts to help build my businesses so
i think that was
important but the classes that
i forget completely what it was about i
will say one thing though
i've learned something from what the
europeans do evan and listen to this
in switzerland i have a stepfather who
swiss he lives in geneva switzerland
i've been going over there for
40 years back and forth take a company
like nestle
they offer an internship program that
they call an apprentice program over
there it's it's almost like the
sorcerer's helper in a disney movie
in high school if you think you like
the food industry maybe you know
nestle's a global food company
they'll let you come in and work on
weekends and afternoons after school
to see what it's like in the real world
even though you're just a teenager
why are they doing that they're trying
to figure out
who is going to be the next asset for
their company that is going to be
someone who attaches themselves to the
business maybe long term
so they get to try you out you get to
try them out they pay you a small
stipend
but that's an apprenticeship what an
opportunity for you
you're a teen you're sitting in a
meeting with a bunch of managers you're
absorbing all that stuff
and you're learning why the hell don't
we do that in north america because
maybe one out of ten is the right person
but once you're indoctrinated if that's
the right word into the
call it the nestle program you're a
nestlet
you're there they want you you want them
and a way your career goes
i love it i think every company in north
america should take that program on and
and
offer this opportunity to kids and their
teens and say look
you want to see what work is you want to
see what it's like
get in here but it also gives you a
chance as an entrepreneur to say i
understand the corporate structure and
now i want to try something a little
different
on my own but i will have had that base
of information not only about what it's
like
but that sector if you love the food
industry
you're with the el supremo and you're
learning about it and then one day you
can split off and say hey nestle i'm
going to build this food business you
want to buy from me have to guess the 50
million
that's the program i like this question
is like how do i prepare for my first
kiss
right and you can you can watch videos
and
you can read a book i agree with you but
at some point you just gotta kiss
and then you feel what it's actually
like yeah right i think that's how you
prepare for entrepreneurship
yeah i i think you're right but but i
don't i also would say
tell me if you agree with this i don't
think everybody should be an
entrepreneur i actually think
only a third of the people can handle
what it takes because it is a
really hard gig you know people try to
make it exciting
running a business is a [ __ ] it's hard
as hell
and not everybody wants to sacrifice the
lifestyle requirement
to do it you're giving up a lot i mean
you're not going to hit all those soccer
games on the weekend you're not going to
go to the family picking you're going to
miss a lot of stuff in your young kids
lives
because you're just working because your
competitor's working that way
i think it's a sacrifice i think
everybody should try
i think it's i think it's worth knowing
like i think how do you know if
you like what should you recommend they
try
as soon as possible like i think getting
exposure is great
how do you know what your favorite food
is if you haven't tried sushi
you could judge sushi and say well
that's raw fish wrapped in seaweed that
sounds disgusting
right if you think it through it doesn't
sound like it's very advertising but
then you try like oh that tastes really
good
i think we pre-judge things and then we
settle on a path
before actually knowing what you could
be
great at so i think everybody should try
entrepreneurship i agree i don't think
it's for everybody i think it's becoming
a lot easier
i think you know if i'm i'm 40 right now
if i look at
the opportunities for me as a 40 year
old compared to my parents when they
were 40
it's a world of difference well you have
more opportunity now because you're in a
digital world
exactly so it's easier you kind of had
to be crazy when my parents were 40
you had to be a little bit crazy to be
an entrepreneur you had to like not fit
into the system
and so you had no other option but to be
an entrepreneur where now
i could have a corporate job i could
succeed in the corporate world but i
choose not to and so it's opening up for
a lot more people
whether the numbers are third or half or
fifth i agree that not everybody should
be an entrepreneur as a profession but i
think everybody should try it
just like everybody should try sushi
well maybe that's the best way to do it
but i would assume if i reverse engineer
that everybody can try it but only one
third is going to make it
sure and it's okay to fail i i'd rather
invest in somebody that's felt a sting
of failure and understood what they did
wrong i mean everybody makes mistakes
that's for sure
and i mean plenty but luckily more has
worked out than has failed and so
you know i i still have capital to
continue to put to work because every
once in a while i get a big hit
i i kind of think about it and now in
retrospect
what a sacrifice of life it is in some
regards but is it worth it yeah you buy
your freedom if you're successful
do whatever you like the reason i'm here
is i want to be here i don't have to be
here either do you
so that's a great thing and i would say
that's worth everybody pursuing so i
think we can agree on that
it's noble i think everybody should try
sushi you just might be allergic to it
what is the most helpful college degree
to help you do well as an entrepreneur
i don't think there is one just
again i went to university of toronto my
my fourth year level u of t is one of
the
top 10 universities in north america
it's up there and fourth year highest
level undergrad class i have a
professor teaching me about
entrepreneurship who hasn't built a
successful business
and our task in the class is to make our
own business plan
i was already running my business at a
biotech software company while being in
in in school and everybody else is
thinking oh start a business okay i'm
gonna make a coffee shop or just like
the basic stuff and i learned nothing i
mean
he's talking to class and i'm on my
laptop working on my business right like
this is
this is not very helpful i don't think a
lot of the education maps to
you being successful as an entrepreneur
i think the connections the resources
one of the things
i wish i did more was connect to the
entrepreneur alumni
from u of t so i'd look at who are the
people who've graduated from u of t from
your university college
who've gone on to do the thing that you
want to do and then say hey i'm an
undergrad at your alumni school
would you be open to having a coffee
with me and you might get a yes
for somebody who otherwise would not
have any time with you just because
you're at
that school i think that's your biggest
hack
more than any degree that you're going
to get it just doesn't map your actions
have to map to your ambitions i don't
see
the paper mapping to success as an
entrepreneur i'm going to answer a
slightly different way
if three years ago when i was asked this
question
you know what degree gives you the
highest chance of success
in a career not necessarily
entrepreneurial but it would apply to
entrepreneurship too
number one would have been engineering
number two engineering number three
engineering and why do i say that
because
you know i teach a lot now i lecture a
lot at places like waterloo mcgill
mit notre dame temple
and i enjoy those classes harvard and
generally it's the graduating cohort of
engineers and about a third of those
classes
go on to take their ideas turn them into
patents turn them into businesses
they form partnerships to do it but i've
changed my mind in the last two years
and i'll tell you why evan
i now have investments in over 50
companies
in mexico canada united states they're
all over the map
i mean in almost every geography in
almost every sector
and since the pandemic hit which has
only been six months now
the number one demand i have for my
companies
are people that can take the concept of
the business and tell a
story about it produce a video do really
rich photography
build out 59 seconds 39 second 29 second
videos
14 second videos to plaster all over
social media to sell product direct to
customer
so if you're a graduate from the arts
or you're a writer or you're a
photographer or an editor or
videographer
all of a sudden i'm paying you 150 000
and i would have thought i could have
hired you for nothing because you're a
starving artist
i was wrong storytelling is part of the
attribute of the new
digital 2.0 economy and it requires the
arts to tell that story it's a whole new
ballgame
and right now we have multiple editors
working for us
across these companies we have hundreds
of photographers shooting our products
we found that if we just upgrade the
quality the video and the imagery and
the story on an already working website
it goes up by 15
so it's not just engineering i would say
it's the arts too now that's a crazy
outcome i could have never foreseen
but do you think the degree matters i
think like if you're an entrepreneur if
you're hiring somebody you're going to
work with a freelancer to come on and
help you
do you care what school they went to and
what well i hate i hate to agree with
you on this one but i do
it doesn't matter and that's horrible
because you're
you're kind of dissing the educational
system when you say that
why would somebody spend two years
getting a postgraduate degree in
business an mba
what a waste of time if you don't think
it gives you any value
and it does give you value in the
context
of people you meet that's why they've
reduced those programs down to one year
now
you know a lot of them are one year
thing and they but you're going to go in
debt 80 000
to do it it has to have some value i
would hope
well if you're gonna go work your way up
td bank or royal bank or bank of america
they still value that they still pride
right the nba but in the entrepreneur
world i just don't think it makes sense
i don't i have
we do not disagree i never ask anybody
when i'm investing in what degree did
you get right i
couldn't get would it would it be a
negative
if somebody listed all of their phds in
whatever
academic background like does it because
i wonder why they wasted all their time
doing that right no
but honestly like after i sold my
company i joined a vc company for
a year and a half and if an owner came
in pitching their business
and they all had phds it would actually
count as a strike against
that they have no real world experience
that they spent all of their good point
in education good point i would rather
have somebody that's been an
operator and done execution of some kind
of business
has those skills maybe succeeded maybe
failed
rather than have another academic and i
don't want to just the academic world
it's important they pursue their own
things but
it has nothing to do you know you're
absolutely right when i think back
in the last 10 years have i ever asked
an entrepreneur that required an
investment for me
where'd you go to school never
don't care i don't care what your dog
was called i don't care what high school
you went to
it doesn't matter like can you execute
this business plan
and what's the plan and what do you
think this product or service is going
to do
yeah you're right i totally agree with
you that's a that's a great
it's i don't want to be negative i'm not
saying you shouldn't pursue an education
but
it's not going to determine your outcome
as an entrepreneur that's fair to say
the political who's going to win the
american election
evan i got to tell you something that
i've learned as an investor
about politics and it started
in the brexit vote in england when i was
trying i have investments in euros in
british pounds
in the swiss francs a man has a european
portfolio and one
of the uh oh shares etfs
and i was trying to buy data about the
outcome of the british election then
the brexit so-called brexit vote because
if
if they elected to leave the eu the
thinking was the british pound would
diminish in value and if they're going
to stay it would go up in value
right and every pollster there said
don't worry about it
they're staying not a problem
wrong and since then every single
election
whether it be canadian mexican us
switzerland france there's been many
many contests that happen
you know and there always is somewhere
with it affects the economics
i have come to the conclusion that polls
do not
predict outcomes at all
they just don't they are completely
irrelevant to the outcome
maybe people don't tell pollsters the
truth
for whatever reason but right now
you know if it says that biden is 10
points ahead or whatever it is
do i think he's going to win the
election no
i wouldn't bet on it i have no idea
who's going to
but i can tell you it's going to be
razor close
and i wouldn't be surprised if trump
wins the election because the polls mean
nothing nothing and they haven't met
anything not just in the u.s
in any jurisdiction you want to test
even in venezuela
even in chile like it doesn't work
hi tell me you're going to vote for go
for yourself i'm not going to tell you
like that's sort of what's going on or
i'm going to lie to you just to have fun
with you
that's what it seems to be and it used
to be more accurate
it was in the 60s uh very rarely that's
a long time ago
but people felt a moral obligation i
think to tell the truth to some stranger
would ask them the question it was
generally done on the street
or by telephone and the polls were
accurate within you know half of a
percent
today they're not even accurate within
10 so the variance
pollsters are actually entertainers now
there's there's nothing
they have a value for business as far as
i'm concerned but it's great to hear
what they
you know they're predicting this
printing that doesn't mean anything
so i'm not pro or con trump or biden i'm
just saying
you don't know the outcome so if you had
to bet on who you think is going to win
the election
who would you put money on my bet would
be to go against the pollsters
so i'd say trump's gonna win that that'd
be my bet
i just whatever they say i go the other
way because they're always wrong
not some of the time 100 percent of the
time
so and i know people hate trump and all
that stuff but
what are you going to do you know it's
sort of a politics is very anytime you
go down that road
you piss off 50 of the people that's
what happens
but i'm not endorsing trump i'm just
saying who i think is going to win
tell me what the poster saying i'll go
the other way that's my point
do you see any impact for entrepreneurs
either way who wins
no it doesn't matter i don't think the
policies are going to change much the
fed's going to remain accommodative if
biden wins i don't think he'll raise
taxes as he says because he can't the
unemployment's at
10 so i mean i i don't think he's going
to hurt the economy i don't think he's
going to help it i don't think
i don't think i think trump's policies
were good for entrepreneurs because he
deregulated it
but i don't think he's a popular
president i mean you know he's very
divisive people
go crazy with him but doesn't mean he's
going to lose
i'm not super following i'll be honest
if you ask me about
youtube league of legends or salsa
dancing
yeah we can go deep what about canada
what about canada i mean there's no they
don't follow it i really feel like i
i don't know that anybody really makes a
big impact for entrepreneurs
me either way yeah i don't know i don't
just i just it's also me
i think entrepreneurs are going to solve
all the world's major problems i don't
think it's whatever they're presented
with they'll figure it out
regardless of the all the problems in
the world entrepreneurs are going to
solve it
it's not necessarily right but it's my
that's how i operate i get it so it
doesn't really matter you know what does
trudeau do what does the next person do
i just don't care i actually think
trudeau's done a really good job
in the pandemic aspect of his mandate i
think he really rallied the country
around health
which was great i don't think he did a
great job in managing the economy prior
to the pandemic
and so that may come and bite him in the
next election and also when you get in
deep into your second mandate in the
canadian parliamentary system
there is there is fatigue there just
people say i want change anyways for the
sake of change
he probably runs that risk he's in a
minority government my bet would be
whoever
takes him on next time probably wins and
that's just the way
politics run in canada but you know
canada is a big part of the north
american economy so it does matter what
happens here
um it's been too bad for the energy
sector because we've lost
you know almost half a million jobs
there that's sad
and how that happened you can argue to
the cows come home but
most economies in the world that are
based on
energy which canada is have figured out
a way to say well maybe we have
hydrocarbons for 20 years let's milk
that and take the money and put it into
something else
we just shut ours down which was a
mistake
what do you think a policy should be for
entrepreneurs
in canada well they should look for the
path of least resistance in terms of
solving problems as you suggested i mean
we have great
mcgill we've got waterloo you know u of
t they spawn all kinds of research
entrepreneurs can take some of these
ideas and turn them into businesses that
solve for people
but i think what's great about canadian
entrepreneurs is they don't just solve
for canada they solve for the globe
i mean they're very global in their
thinking which they have to be we're
only two and a half percent of the
world's economy this
is like the state of california the
whole country
where 37 million there are 37 million
but do you think there's a policy that
the government
of canada could put up that would
actually make a meaningful impact for
entrepreneurs
yeah they should reduce taxes for um
entrepreneurial companies that are
canadian-owned they should endorse
and support those to get going um
i i left canada when the learning
company
uh um to grow uh it was the fastest
growing
educational software company in the
world and then the ndp
came in bob ray was was the leader
and um uh i think that was in the
uh early 90s and we went to raise
capital in london england and they said
well we don't invest in canadian
companies you have the highest corporate
tax rate
in in the world um and
people don't want to live there because
it's a socialist country i went whoa
so i went to see the government said hey
guys my competitors are raising money
all around the world and i can't get any
can you change our tax rate so i compete
they said absolutely not i said well
watch this
i am not a mine i am not you know a
diamond mine i'm not a
foreigner watch this i'm going to take
all these people and move them
in one day and you're going to lose this
entire business even
they didn't care and so we moved it to
boston
and became the largest software
educational software company in the
world sold it for 4.2 billion
and i don't think we had we we had 10
000 employees and i think
none of them were canadian except the
founders it was sad
that's the trouble with bad policy uh
particularly in a tech industry and so
i would hope you know i know bob ray has
um changed his stripes and said he's not
a socialist but i don't believe it
so i i lived through that with him that
guy's a socialist
and so i'll just say that right on the
record
a little a little politics in there
tips on creating a sustainable business
i think finding your direct path to cash
flow as soon as possible is super
important
i think so many times entrepreneurs have
these big visions of what they're going
to do
and and for it to work you need to have
a million people using your thing
because the economics just don't work
out so what's going to
i want to find a business model that's
going to bridge me to that path
instead of i need to keep raising money
that's going to keep
running out at some point so you have
your big vision awesome
how we're going to make money even if
it's like one little tiny piece of it
how can you make money doing that big
thing so
for example youtube if we're doing this
if my goal is to have a big youtube
channel
and i need to have cameras and camera
guy and all that that's all going to
cost money
great that'll pay off when i have a
million subscribers but
first getting started i would look at
okay while i'm building my brand and
trying to do this thing that's in line
with my big vision
how can i sell my services to kevin
and make money from kevin being his
video guy as well
so i can find buying on my cameras to go
do the thing that i want to do
right and people often miss that step
and just substitute it with
fundraising or feeling like they need to
have fundraising
and then they never actually take the
actions so sustainability at the
beginning is figuring out i love b2b at
the beginning
because i think b2c is just a giant
money pit to get going
uh finding that path to cash flow so
that you can sustain your business
business to business is a little tougher
but but the clients if it's a
subscription service is a fantastic way
to make money i agree
i'm going to interpret this question a
little differently tips on create
creating a sustainable business i'm
going to talk about sustainability as a
theme
for business because in the last two
years i have realized something has
changed with the consumer
i used to think that sustainability
green
renewables all that stuff was a
marketing tactic to say that you cared
about the environment
and to try and get customers to buy the
product because they think you did
that's not true anymore people are
making purchase decisions
about the fact that they don't want
waste let's just take plastics as an
example
i have a company called blue land and
what it does is it
it crystallizes cleaning fluids like
dish soap and like
surface cleaners so that you don't have
to buy it in a in a single use
plastic jug they ship you the tablet
like an alka-seltzer you drop it into
reusable glass or plastic bottle
and you use it again and again and again
you never throw it out
that business i thought would be very
niche and marginal
it came out of the gate and within
months was doing three million dollars a
month in sales
it's a monster success because people
actually make the purchase decision on
sustainability
and lack of plastics going into the
environment
that's not a trend that's a fact and so
now i'm really looking for more
businesses that
that can take because you're right b to
c is tough it's really tough because you
people don't know you're there but when
you have a theme saying look we
our simple mission is give you the very
best detergent you can buy
but not in a plastic bottle that's a
message
and a third of the population says
that's for me
i'm sick of throwing out these plastic
bottles i know it's doing the
environment harm
that's sustainability so a different
twist on it yeah yeah you want
the environmental way i like it too what
do you think the markup is on that like
if the same product
one's environmental one's not how much
more would people well you know we
learned if you charge more
they won't buy it so you're going to
have to figure out how to solve for the
sustainability at not a higher price
so blue land did it by crystallizing the
tablet and reducing the
cost of shipping two gallons of water
that's
heavy so they were able to take the
reduction in shipping cost
and apply it to marketing and people
said yeah that makes sense you're just
gonna
overnight me the tablets and i've
already got my kit with the bottle it
says
surface cleaner or toilet cleaner or
whatever it is and
that works so we're not charging more
it's the same price except
we don't have to throw plastic in the
ocean you can't
ask for more because consumers don't
have more to give you
but if you can deliver it at the same
price
you've got an advantage that's what i
think because you're right you've nailed
the right issue like you can't you can't
say well pay 30 more because it's
sustainable
no doesn't work has to be the same
that's good though
all right next what are you most proud
of oh
that's a good one
okay evan let's start with you what are
you most proud of i i don't know i don't
even know how to answer that question
um i don't think about these things
i'm probably most proud of myself
[Laughter]
that's good just of the the talk that i
have
honestly is when i do difficult things i
reward myself
mentally when i just did something i was
afraid to do i was afraid to go speak on
that stage or
travel to that country and you know i
might disappoint somebody and then
and then i did it the self-talk is i'm
so amazing oh my god i did that i'm a
genius right that's
good that's a constant self-talk i think
that's what actually allows you to be
humble i think when you when you deeply
love yourself and are proud of yourself
that actually gives you the humility to
have you
you could come in and say hey you suck
at all these things like great
tell me like tell me where i suck and
how i can get even better
um so yeah so i'm most proud of myself i
like that answer that's a good one i i
i think um that's it's a tough one
you know i'm proud of uh i like i like
to spend a little bit more time with my
family these days because i didn't when
i was
you know running my business um and i'm
proud of where my kids have gotten to
but i have to tell you the truth it
wasn't really me that raised it was my
wife because i was absent
for ten years you know from zero to ten
uh learning company was global so i was
always traveling and maybe i get home
one day a week
so i'm proud of how they came up but
it's really my wife that you get the
credit for that
and i always tell entrepreneurs if
you're if you have kids you've got to
realize
there's going to be a balance there and
sacrifice and you may not be the person
that racism may be the significant other
that does it
whether you're a man or woman it's you
got to be indifferent to that doesn't
matter
but i'm i'm proud of them um
i'm proud that i survived politics that
was i'll tell
make an observation of and you probably
haven't run for anything politically yet
um my mom did so we showed you through
it you know then
so the difference between celebrity and
politics is in celebrity
people don't like you because there's
always somebody who just doesn't like
who you are
and i have lots of that uh being you
know the tough guy on shark tank and all
that stuff
but i'm just the guy that tells the
truth but there's a lot of people that
don't like that
but politics is different in politics
people
hate you uh 50 of the population hates
you
because of your ideology not dislike you
hate you and when that when that
manifests itself in front of you for the
first time it's quite a shock
and it happened to my wife and i in a
basketball game during the toronto
raptors
run up to you know championship uh back
when they were competing in in 2016. the
police had to come out and protect
us it was really weird the security and
i thought
well this is different this ain't shark
tank anymore
you know we're not in kansas toto this
is different
and that's that was very disturbing for
me to realize
uh and now i appreciate the sacrifice
politicians make
regardless of party it doesn't matter
because there's going to be some
percentage
whether you're an american or south
american or swiss or french politician
or canadian
50 of the population hates you and i
don't know what this has to do with
being proud of myself but
it really when i think about it i'm
happy and proud that i survived that
because it was really bad and it taught
me a lot about
respecting those that want to serve
because i used to be a cynical person
against politicians now i realize
their services thank you for your
service i say to them
because it ain't fun so you're proud of
yourself too
i i'm proud of myself i'm what you know
what i've accomplished and what i'm
still doing and
i feel the same way you do i think your
answer it makes a lot of sense why
you have to encourage yourself who else
is going to do it for you i mean you got
to say look
that was a great day i had that was a
bad day what that i learned from it all
that stuff
but i find successful entrepreneurs have
a certain pride in in their mission
in what they do and even though when
they fail they're still proud that they
tried
and that's what matters and a great way
to end it
i've really enjoyed our time today it's
great you're a good guy
i'm going to endorse you
that's fantastic this is only half of
the questions that kevin and i went over
if you want to see the other half
go check out kevin's channel the link is
right there next to me
i'll see you there